[Music]
2015 was a year to remember especially
for Gearheads like us so let's take a
look back at the five best products of
the year starting at number five Siri
show me pictures from Lake Tahoe if
telling people what to do is your thing
then you loved all the voice control
devices that made their way into your
home Amazon's Alexa Apple Siri and
Microsoft's Cortana made big leaps in
2015 number four goes to the Apple iPad
Pro when this thing arrived we all
thought it was a little too big and a
little too pricey but after using it we
can see it's the future of Mobility for
the power user but only when the
software catches
up wired's number three Microsoft
Surface Book the PC giant finally
decided to make a laptop its beauty and
smarts surprised many people it was a
huge step forward for Windows 10 as the
OS is clearly going through a rebirth
that's a signal of good things to
come the spread of hoverboards comes in
at number two such a deep cultural
impact from such a weird and ungainly
thing who to thk best part though the
thousands of videos of hoverboard
crashes the Apple watch clinches the top
spot for us this year one of the most
important companies in technology made
this new product category cool Apple
injected itself into Both Worlds of
fashion and horology wearables are
without out of doubt the biggest thing
this
year